okay well if that person was of a
different color which is an issue that
we have in this country would they have
gotten that fair treatment right i think
really that's what people are upset
about of course even if they agree that
he was supposed to be left free the hard
part is is that we have seen time and
time again in this country like
if it was the other way around i don't
know if that would have been the case
yes because we saw we saw with the case
with the young lady who was
i think she was like sex trafficked or
or something like that right and she she
murdered her rapist right yeah
yeah yeah in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the
genius brain podcast i am your host
david soh and we have double ed time
today
in the house
[Laughter]
just got his car broke
come on man i just forgot about it you
gotta remind me of this [ __ ] again yo
the inconsistency of like the [ __ ] they
stole from my car it just doesn't make
sense i mean i told you guys before we
started this but all right so check it
out guys um i got my i got
anything of value stolen from my car
obviously but these [ __ ] also
decided to steal a used face mask uh
a car
manual i like the way this one smells
car registration but yet they left
behind things like umbrella uh hand
sanitizer uh my my fast track pass um
beanies that i had in the trunk like
what
what what is the right there's no they
took your registration which they don't
need but they left your fast pass which
they could use
exactly so it's like what the that's
that's why it makes me think it was a
crackhead who did it oh it's for sure a
[ __ ] crackhead dude oh yeah the
registration was like are these some
stocks or something
when i was in this means i owned the car
it's mine
when i was in a ucr there was a dude
named peter peter there was only a
couple of people who had cars right so
peter before he got like a toyota
remember that toyota solara oh yeah the
camry coupe yeah the weird looking camry
coupe so that was the car that he got
after this break-in yeah so there was
only a couple of people in college at
the time that were friends of mine that
actually had a car but the people who
did have a car they were all hoopties
there was this dude uh peter there's
this other dude named phil and phil had
this [ __ ] hooptie ass like mpv van
you know the nba oh yeah my mom had one
for like 15 years yeah we had that [ __ ]
too man tell you something i love honda
elements and i love mpv's
[ __ ]
peter
in the parking structure that he parked
his car at next to the apartment that we
lived in his [ __ ] got broken into this
is the funniest thing this full had his
car broken into they smashed the windows
his car was so [ __ ] shitty i kid you
not they just stole
a single gum
out of the mini package
right and then he found a dollar in
there that wasn't there before
he found it i think they smashed his
windows and they gave him a dollar
that's how shitty his [ __ ] car was
dude
dude he felt so bad for him like yo you
need it more than
and the funny thing is the fact that he
knew a single double gum was taken out
is hilarious i was saving that later
they [ __ ] stole my gum man
i'm like what you mean he goes i has
three
oh [ __ ] this dude peter was [ __ ]
hilarious he told us this one story in
college that had me dying and this is
like when you know you're
a little different from everybody else
so this is that time where i think when
everybody gets to know each other they
kind of open up and they tell personal
stories about themselves so peter
[ __ ]
i forgot who shared the story i think it
was a dude named daryl that was sharing
his story about he kind of grew up
without a father and his
mom was
a single mom that raised him and then i
think peter wanted to like join in on
the sadness to kind of say like i relate
to you i have a sad story too but he's
like a vietnamese fob but the way he
said it had me i busted up laughing
because he goes my uncle
went fishing on a boat
a wave hit him he'd die
i started dying laughing and i felt so
bad but i couldn't stop laughing dude
wife hit him he died
it's cause it's like a vietnamese fob
too so he's talking about the story like
in vietnam but the way he described it
was just so sudden wave hit him
he died
[Laughter]
what was that what was that uh meme from
he's so basically they're having an
intervention
um his their dad is a drug addict and
the kids are trying to tell him like yo
enough is enough you're you know and
then
that's how he breaks into he just
he's definitely never cried before yeah
this is the first time he's ever so
awkward and so unexpected like it's just
an outburst out of nowhere but i just
want you to know
through all the pain
i still love you
[Laughter]
that happened at the same time there was
that clip it was in africa and there was
an interviewer asking this person why
they're gay have you seen it
i haven't seen that one and it is
literally the funniest [ __ ] thing
it's this janky production it's like
some african news type of thing i don't
know how legitimate it is but it's
she's like some type of either gay
rights activist or she just happens to
be gay but he's interviewing her and off
the jump he goes why are you gay
why are you gay
you are gay like what the [ __ ] is going
on
and she's like trying to explain because
i i think
he's like very christian you know
talking about like how being gay
because you know you are gay why are you
gay
i don't understand why you are gay
is it because i
because i'm gay no but why are you gay
literally the cold opening question is
what was when was this from this was
years ago okay so like back in the days
back in the day it was around the same
time i saw both those clients
so [ __ ] funny public access tv yeah
yeah yeah are you gay well this is a
weird transition
we're actually going to talk about and i
tweeted this a while ago
um during the whole kyle rittenhouse
thing and people were part of the
patreon and stuff i um i have somebody
who reads the the requests and stuff uh
i'll be i'll get back on the patreon
it's been a while there's a lot of [ __ ]
going on right now what you mean you got
somebody who reads the request to you
yeah and they and they they uh they kind
of just did they did they bring a scroll
with them
but they're gonna break down like topic
suggestions and whatever yeah so um
this one specifically was hard to talk
about because it was still an ongoing
trial we're going to talk about kyle
rittenhouse right now we mentioned about
the kyle rittenhouse thing when when did
this happen it was last year yeah it was
last year um and the verdict just
happened about a week ago yeah so just
to just to kind of if you don't know
which you probably already know a
general idea about what this is kyle
rittenhouse is a young man under the age
of 18 at the time i think he's 18. he is
18 now he's 18 now i think he was 17
then he decided to cross-state lies it
was from illinois to wisconsin to
wisconsin
he had a semi-automatic rifle and
according to him
and we're going to go through the case
um just factually and then we're going
to discuss it but uh carried an ar-15 he
said that he went over there to protect
uh small businesses because of the
writing that was happening during the
whole blm protest um
he decides to go there long story short
and once again we'll go into detail two
people he shot two people um shot killed
two people shot and killed two people
injured one shot him in the bicep blew
off his bicep
uh this was huge news right and the
reason why i didn't want to discuss it
during because there wasn't all the
information wasn't out there so i
couldn't really collectively think of
what to say right because it was so
brand new and to kind of put my thoughts
and ideas into a hat where i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on doesn't really
make sense to me right yeah and it would
just be a discussion of what ifs at that
point um which i wasn't really
interested in yeah so now that the the
verdict is out kyle written house was
acquitted of all charges right right and
there was about
what's up five that was about five five
charges right yes five felony charges
and there was the misdemeanor charge for
the miner with the possession of the
firearm which was dismissed yeah yeah
and so this kind of goes hand-in-hand
with
i mean we all know this like this this
country has
largely have dealt with the major issues
of racism right and we specifically in
the last three years has been brought to
light once again not that it hasn't
before
but with the whole kyle rittenhouse case
it was
it was kind of nuts even when it was
happening right it was this young man
and you know
it was hard to process because i didn't
know what was going on there was new
clips being shown every day of people
recording what was happening yeah and i
just when i first saw it it was
obviously it's rage like do i as
personally as a as a human being feel he
should be walking away scratch-free
absolutely [ __ ] lutely not he
murdered two people
but now we have to go into this case and
why he would he walked away without
having anything to happen to him that's
the thing though like what you're
talking about of getting all the
correct information
as bits and pieces of information was
coming out as footage was coming out
there was a lot of irresponsibility on
the side of the media with a lot of bias
a lot of sensational you know
sensationalism sensationalizing
headlines right so it was hard to get an
objective clear picture of what exactly
had happened but once those details did
come out and
anybody who followed the trial pretty
closely or even just follow the
important parts of it
it's hard to say that
justice wasn't served you know i in my
opinion justice was served now you might
not like that call you might not like
what happened but it doesn't change from
the fact this is not about what you like
or dislike it's not about what you feel
it's not about your opinion it's about
guilty or not guilty and
stuff that they were trying to charge
right and beyond a reasonable doubt you
can a reasonable person cannot say based
on the evidence that's been presented
based on the arguments from both sides
you cannot say beyond a reasonable doubt
that kyle rittenhouse was guilty yeah so
the this is the the hard part and the
hard pill for a lot of us to swallow
right because even for me i don't like
that little [ __ ] right like i i
i [ __ ] hate that little [ __ ]
especially you know originally when he
first was brought back over yeah to be
put into jail and he was released
he was [ __ ] at a bar celebrating yeah
right he was wearing a t-shirt i forgot
what it said exactly but it wasn't
exactly something that made him look
like a very good [ __ ] person right
out celebrating at a bar even if it's in
self-defense you know having killed two
people the the other issue that we have
with this is that that a lot of people
feel is the rhetoric specifically of
people who are in support of him saying
that he is an american hero
this causes so much fuel to a flame that
doesn't need to be
to label him as an american hero yeah
like this is a true american blows my
[ __ ] mind so the problem with the
whole case is
in a lot of situations actually that
we've seen in the past few years ever
since trump came into office is
everything is about political ideologies
now whether it supports it or detracts
from it and and each side is trying to
figure anything they can to latch on to
it and in this case
it became a thing of political ideology
right and that's what i hate like how
it's become so black and white it's one
or the other thing now
the critical thinking level of people in
this country is astonishing like the how
that level is right i want people to
really take away from this right and
once again i'm already putting up the
premise that i [ __ ] hate this kid
but the idea of
convicting somebody and making them
guilty you have to remember it's beyond
a reasonable doubt and and you cannot
let those biases affect your your
judgment in how you look at the evidence
that's been presented yeah that's what
i'm talking about it doesn't matter
whether or not you like this kid or what
he's about even if this kid is racist
right
what did he do during basically
everything that transpired to make him
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt right
that's what i'm saying like people want
to inject their personal opinions their
personal political ideologies their
personal thoughts into this thing and
and and make it so to support that but
that's not how the law works now we're
gonna we'll obviously talk more about
this when we go into the case because
there's a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
happened in between this that allowed
him to walk away scratch-free right
there's the prosecution was [ __ ]
trash yeah like we could get into that
whole thing
was [ __ ] terrible there was a lot of
[ __ ] with the judge there was a lot of
people that were trying to intervene in
terms of the outcome of the case that
just didn't help at all like trying to
dox some of the some of the um what do
you call them the jury the jury try to
dox the jury find out where they were
going media like this
people might think that they had they
were trying to do something great but it
doesn't
when people already set with their
certain ideas let's say that they
already had a uh they were supposed to
be unbiased which rarely any of us
really are right we can try our best to
be both it's hard it's hard to right
let's say there was somebody on the jury
that was like you know what i truly
believe that uh he should walk away
scratch-free because i i i feel like as
an american it makes more sense right
you threatening those people saying that
if you
don't do as i tell you i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you or i'm gonna come after you
it's not gonna make them change their
minds you're only proving their point
yeah it doesn't help there were so many
[ __ ] up things that happened in
between this that people don't want to
take responsibility for for example like
media coverage people trying to dox
these people which is [ __ ]
insane yeah you know what i mean like
especially when you want let's say if we
put it on the flip side let's say we
were there and we're supposed to be we
want these people to be as unbiased as
possible right to kind of look at the
facts and give me a fair trial if you
were in that seat would you have would
you have accepted that type of treatment
probably not yeah you know but but you
know what you just said about that
there's
[ __ ] to unpack there too because that's
one of my
i guess takeaways from this whole thing
it's like because you just said if we
were there yeah if we were on trial we
were kyle rittenhouse but instead were
kyle kim's or kyle parks right would we
get the same kind of treatment and
justice this podcast is sponsored by
better help is there something
interfering with your happiness or is
preventing you from achieving your goals
my friends you already know what's up
with better help i have been
using better health for the longest time
and i gotta tell you something man still
great still awesome and i know a lot of
you have been messaging me and have been
thanking me don't thank me thank
yourself for getting the help that you
need and if better help was the one for
you i'm glad that it helped you out like
it did for me betterhelp is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
therapists if needed because this isn't
a one size fits all thing as you guys
know
sometimes when you if you haven't done
therapy before sometimes you go to a
therapist and something's not clicking
well the great thing about better help
is that you can go ahead and switch that
therapist if it's not working with you
so there's nothing wrong with you
there's nothing wrong with this
sometimes you just gotta find one that
matches betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today and in fact
so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
visit betterhelp.com
genius that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
a special offer for genius brain
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius
questionable at best questionable at
best as a minority as a black brown
yellow face on the stand with these
charges against us where we are we gonna
get the same kind of treatment yeah the
fact that it's questionable at best and
not a resounding yes
shows you the problems that exist in our
justice system you know yeah and that's
the hard thing to to kind of walk away
from right and i think that's the part
that really upsets people even if let's
say that a lot of people understand what
we're saying right now okay well beyond
a reasonable doubt he's not guilty
it's hard for them to also say well if
that person was of a different color
which is an issue that we have in this
country would they have gotten that fair
treatment right i think really that's
what people are upset about of course
even if they agree that he was supposed
to be let free the hard part is is that
we have seen time and time again in this
country like
if it was the other way around i don't
know if that would have been the case
yes because we saw we saw with the case
with the young lady who was
i think she was like sex trafficked or
or something like that right and she she
murdered her rapist right yeah
yeah yeah what was her name i can't
remember but i can't remember either but
do you remember that case i do um yeah
well she was a
sex life essentially she was being
prostituted out by his pimp and
i guess he at one point had threatened
her life or something and she knew she
wasn't some [ __ ] with him so she killed
him
she killed him and then they put her in
jail for like 15 years yeah
right and then we see cases like that
where it's like okay how come this is in
self-defense
you know and she's of a different skin
color so when we look at these cases
it's hard for
me as a human being or any person in
this country to say like okay well this
justice system is fair right so
it's hard to not put our personal
emotions when we see the opposite happen
to somebody who is not of the same skin
color as this person yeah and this is
where this conversation comes where i
think a lot of people were saying um i
don't understand how this is a race
issue when he killed
oh he killed two white people and the
other person was white as well yeah it
goes beyond that right we're talking
about this case specifically for a young
white man who if it was in this position
where someone if this was a person of
color would they have gotten that same
treatment but the also issue is that is
that we can't play with it because we
don't [ __ ] right right but but
based on the things that we've seen
happen yeah that's what i'm saying it's
questionable at best whether or not we
would get a fair treatment if you're a
minority you know with the same charges
that's why i'm saying like it's okay to
have an issue with that it's okay to be
angry with that but that's something
that's separate to this yes you can't
because you feel that way about this
it's not like
you can't translate that feeling into
this you know it's not the same like
they can exist separately like this guy
was not guilty and now you're upset with
the way the our laws and justice system
is right how i feel about is that kyle
rittenhouse is this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] that feels like he's a vigilante
and he could put take justice into his
own own hands and he found the right
loopholes that allowed him to get away
scratching but i don't that okay but
we'll get into that part like yeah of
the opinions of like the character
profiles yeah okay so before i start
reading this there's something that i
know that people want to address that i
i had to look up myself right so
uh before the case even started the
the charge of him
uh holding on to an illegal weapon it
was it was a legal weapon but illegal in
the sense that he was a 17 year old yeah
was dropped before the case started yeah
and the reason why is because there was
legal jargon that was very confusing
that's actually left up to the judge
that decides whether he could be
prosecuted for it or not yeah which is
the the type of weapon that we he had
and the gun so i'll leave an article in
a link that you guys could read to
yourself there's a lot of legal jargon
behind it but essentially from what i
got from it is that the length of the
barrel in which he had was actually
categorized as deemed okay in the state
of wisconsin right because it's deemed
as a hunting rifle yeah so yeah the
ar-15
classic hunting right the classic
hunting the ar-15 rifle right and so
this is an area that's very muddled and
confused right um it sets a very
dangerous precedent for something in the
future right because the reason why that
thing was set up because they didn't
want young kids to be walking around
with assault rifles or whatever right or
or handguns was the the law was designed
for hunting that that's the thing
exactly but it didn't cover the whole
right right it's a it's a very poorly
worded exactly so this is this is what
i'm talking about where it sets up a
very bad precedence right so somebody
else carries an ar-15 there are 17 they
go hold on this is actually legal for me
because the the length of the barrel
is
it basically says that i'm not guilty of
anything yeah yeah you you can get
charged for whatever whatever for for a
minor holding a a weapon that shouldn't
they shouldn't have yeah but in terms of
the extent of the law it's kind of like
a slap on the wrist i guess i guess the
quote-unquote loophole you were talking
about has to do with the fact that he
was 17 and he purchased it through
another guy his friend illegally yeah an
older friend who bought it right but
then it was in kyle in the house's
possession right so it was his friend's
stepfather's home where the gun was at
in kenosha i believe um now his friend
is also uh has charges against him too
right but for selling a weapon to a
miner or something like that i forgot
what it is so that's isn't that some
weird [ __ ] though how does that case get
dropped for him but then he well they're
trying to get that case thrown out now
because of that because of this
presidency because of the statute in the
law
this is what i'm talking about so that
kind of what i'm getting to this is that
when these type of laws are set from
what i've read it's left up to the judge
and it's usually in the favor of
somebody like kyle rittenhouse well
anything else to be fair to be fair if
i'm recalling this correctly the judge
the the the prosecution tried to or the
defense team tried to get that case or
that charge thrown out twice previously
the judge denied it twice
third time though they presented the
statute i believe
and
the judge even admitted that it was
confusing the law how this thing was
worded right but if you do look into
bait so the law if you look at the base
of the law which says you know a minor
cannot carry a firearm open carry a
firearm even the open carry is legal in
wisconsin yeah based on that alone he's
guilty but then like you said within the
statute
there is
a little caveat in that law talking
about the length of the barrel and so it
negates the base law because of that
yeah and so that was kind of what they
used to get that charge dropped i guess
there was another little a part of it
where he was with the guy that sold him
the gun yeah he was with him he they
were partners doing their whatever [ __ ]
that they were doing the vigilante
justice well i guess
what they argue was that he was out
there because he was an emt in training
as a young intern or something so he was
out there doing
quote-unquote medical work he was
strapped with an ar-15 yeah yeah so so
look there was poor judgment in a lot of
a lot of uh the situations uh during
this whole thing yes right yes but again
that doesn't change the fact of what
we're talking about is was this guy
guilty or not we haven't even gone to
that yeah i'm only clarifying why people
are asking why he wasn't charged with
holding in a for a minor to have this
right this weaponry right and so it was
dropped because of these reasons there
was just a lot of weird legal jargon and
it was left up to the judge to decide
whether they were and there was also
this talk to you but i read up in the
article it's like
if that was something that was left
around they kind of wanted to eliminate
it so he had no fall back so they wanted
to make sure that these charges were
pressed more because it's like so
because the fallback would be well let's
just get him with this stuff instead of
this well that was the best shot that
they had yeah at making any charge stick
the other felony charge now
also too it's important to note that
this
charge for the possession of a firearm
minor with the possession of a firearm
was a misdemeanor charge exactly so he
wasn't gonna do hard time for it even if
he did get charged with it but again i
think it's important to point out that
the judge
denied twice for the dismissal of it so
if if people want to use that as some
sort of bias oh yeah he's a pro kyle
written house type of dude yeah he
denied it twice because i think the
confusion surrounding the wording
in the law right but then i don't think
that's the case like the only thing i
want people to clarify is that it was
very muddied and then
typically and what i've read in a couple
articles yeah is that either way
typically it's gonna it it was gonna be
for kyle written house or not yeah so
it's it wasn't something that was so
clear-cut yeah so i think
that was a detail that was left out on
almost everything because that was the
thing i didn't understand it's like how
come at least you should be charged for
this but it was dropped before the case
even started so this is where we have to
start fresh so if you guys want to read
up on that i'll link the article as to
why it happened that way and then you
guys can go in yeah you can actually
look into the law itself i read the law
and the statute it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense it's confusing it's
confusing right but then the statute i
could see why it was dismissed because
of that statute because that statute
makes it pretty clear on basically the
whole length and a minor being able to
carry a firearm in that instance
yeah and once again to
like i i don't agree with it because in
terms of
for future cases because it's a very
dangerous precedent right it's not a
good law it's a
they need they need to write that law
there needs to be a little more
specifically
rifles not ar and they have to list out
the guns they aren't allowed it was just
so generalized and stupid and this is
why it happened this way right so
from that point on now you guys can
figure out what happens next right so
uh
one more thing dave before you get into
it two uh there was also a lot of hubla
about the judge not allowing the
prosecution team to refer to the
deceased as victims right
i agreed with that though i agreed with
that because that implies guilt that
implies that kyle rittenhouse is a
murderer before he's been convicted of
anything right and and and and for the
sake of a fair trial to not have any you
know priests
we can't bring that up yet because we
haven't gotten to the case so you bring
that up when we start going we're going
to go this piece by piece okay right so
i'm just reading this up from this is
there's i mean there was two articles
there's one from um cbs and abc and
they're relatively the same so this is a
non-opinion piece this is just uh noting
what happened in the trial uh so who is
kyle written house britain house was
said was 17 at the time we'll skip that
we already talked about that
written house told jurors he is now
studying nursing at arizona state
university in a statement the school
clarified that rent house enrolled in
online classes but has not been admitted
to the university's nursing school he
also said he had worked as a lifeguard
in kenosha and was part of an emt cadet
program where he learned cpr and basic
first aid at trial he admitted that he
falsely claimed to be a certified emt on
the night of the shooting yeah yeah he
did do that his attorney said written
house has suffered ptsd following the
shooting and is currently in therapy so
that is the general summary of who kyle
rittenhouse is right
who are the victims um i think this is
important for people to know
joseph rosenbaum 36 was the first person
fatally shot by rittenhouse the teen
claims rosenbaum chased him and grabbed
his firearm before rittenhouse shot him
four times
also uh rosenbaum had just been
discharged from the hospital that night
yeah so could do continue he had never
physically touched written house
um rosenbaum was reportedly homeless uh
struggled with bipolar disorder and just
that day had been released from a
hospital after attempting suicide the
report said he spent years in prison for
sexual contact with a minor
that is who joseph rosenbaum is right
right uh
which i guess
i don't know if that's like
well it kind of shows like the mental
state of who this person was right you
know that he's mentally unstable but the
thing is when you hear the testimony of
other people who are there it supports
that because he was out there causing a
lot of tension yelling profanities
i believe he even threatened kyle
rittenhouse i'm gonna cut your heart out
you [ __ ] or some [ __ ] like that
times like he called him the n-word too
yeah so he was he was yelling
he was defacing property and doing all
kinds of illegal [ __ ] you know so nobody
knows why he was out there yeah yeah
it's like there was no clear reason
you know and i think an important thing
to note too is that this is not to
justify his death but is to kind of in
kind of like in case context context
matters
you know once again like we we have to
know about this context right this is
not to say that this person deserved to
die that is not no no no no no no
i guess he had spotted ridden house
earlier and was threatening him i mean
obviously it's because he had an ar-15
strapped around him so he was making
these threats at him and then um he
actually went and charged him because
ridden house was trying to put out a
fire and that pissed off well we'll get
into the details of like each one i
guess once we get into the meats of it
because i definitely got stuff i want to
talk about there too so let's talk about
anthony huber anthony huber was 26 was
shot in the chest by rinton house born
in kenosha he died four days after his
birthday according to an obituary
ringhouse claims hubert had kicked him
in the face and struck him in the head
with his skateboard the teen says he
shot huber as he tried to reach for his
weapon
um
there was footage of this yeah right so
he and in court he did have a weapon he
had a pistol or a gun no no no he didn't
he didn't that that's uh gross croods
that's gage gross crew it's a third guy
ah yeah i'm sorry so does it say
anything about anthony humor in there
being acquaintances with jacob blake
because he was acquaintances with jacob
blake and and so he already had
a very clear bias he was a skateboard
guy yeah yeah yeah jacob blake i mean
i'm sorry huber was a skateboard guy
yeah yeah and jacob blake is the reason
why they were protesting right yes yeah
jacob blake was the reason why they're
opposed so that's why he was out there
you know um so he jacob blake was a guy
who was shot multiple times yeah by the
cops and it was paralyzed yes yeah yes
and so huber it's important to note
huber was an acquaintance with jacob
blake and also
he doesn't have a very perfect um
character profile either being in and
out of prison choked his brother for 10
seconds because he wouldn't clean the
room
got locked up in prison got out kicked
his sister for something got right back
into prison
so you know this dude had mental issues
it was a representation of like and i
think like when this information is
presented and we'll obviously talk about
it too is that
this kind of just goes all for kyle
written house to talk about the mental
state of people who attacked him right
because
when i first heard this case just to go
back and
even for me
the way they painted these people that
they kind of made them seem as if they
were peaceful protesters like saints
saints and that obviously affected my
opinion not once again it's not to talk
about whether these people deserve to
die but we do have to paint this case
truthfully yeah with the right brush
again context context matters and that's
why i'm saying it was so [ __ ] like
irritating how
biased and and like
misrepresentative the media was in terms
of like showcasing what happened the
people involved in it who these people
are and and look man some of these media
outlets omitted important details
again context right in order to favor
their kind of sentiment or their opinion
right so is this is it pronounced gait
gage gage gross croots yeah 27 was the
sole survivor of the shootings moments
after hubert was killed written house
shot gross crews in the arm gross group
says he lost 90 of his bicep
at trial he admitted that he thought he
was going to die rittenhouse said he
reacted to seeing his handgun which
gross crews explained to the court that
he pulled out because he thought
rittenhouse was an active shooter
um
this was all seen gross groups did have
a gun yes at that point
was he an active shooter no he wasn't he
was never an active shooter during this
whole thing
and that's that's okay but again we'll
get into that later so let's talk about
the charges now right count one first
degree reckless homicide use of a
dangerous weapon count two first degree
recklessly endangering safety use of a
dangerous dangerous weapon count three
first degree intentional homicide use of
a dangerous weapon count four attempted
first-degree intentional homicide use of
a dangerous weapon count five first
degree recklessly endangering safety use
of a dangerous weapon a six-count
possession of a dangerous weapon by a
person under 18 was dropped by the judge
before both sides began their closing
arguments as we explained before why so
now that you guys know that so if
convicted of the intentional homicide
charge written house could face life in
prison
um
so that's basically kind of like the
gist of what people are going for yeah
this is who he is yeah and kind of just
to clarify things because i think a lot
of us
we kind of get emotional about this
stuff first and
we don't ever want to read about the
details because it's really heavy
because sometimes when we some when we
want a specific outcome that we already
feel is justice
we kind of
steer away from information because we
know a little part of us might read
something that might make them seem like
they're right and you're wrong yeah and
i'm guilty of that sometimes where
i i get scared of reading sometimes
facts because i want to be right so bad
that i'd rather just not read something
and then justify my feelings by just the
small facts that i already know yeah
and it's important for us in this type
of case because it's such a national
thing because it kind of affects how a
lot of people view this country to kind
of read up on these details this is a
huge case
especially if you want to say something
substantial about it you know make sure
you get all the facts yeah and make sure
you're objective about it you know not
not injecting bias or or you know
subjectiveness into it like really it's
hard it's
hard it is hard it is hard but
in this case where somebody else's life
is basically up in the air based on what
the verdict is i mean look to be fair i
think even though he got a not guilty
verdict this kid's life is ruined for
the rest of his life because people are
not going to be happy there's it's a
fact that there's a ton of people i
don't think his life is going to be
ruined i think so i i don't think so
i think he could find his circle i think
here's the reason why yeah it's because
the where he lives and who supports him
is huge yeah he has more support than he
has people who hate him that's the sad
part his
i mean it's about 50 50. oh man because
at the end of the day the people that
hate him don't live around him oh okay
that's true yeah like his his immediate
circle and on top of that too
people also have to realize too a
majority of the people who are in the
hoop like who are visibly upset about
this it's only represented through
twitter instagram and everything else
like a very small percentage of the
population actually uses that a lot
we we always think that twitter
instagram and youtube is a
representation of the whole of the
majority of the population and it's
actually not it's like less than 10 it's
very small speaking of twitter um they
there was like this uh information that
came out like i i don't know how they
got that information put it together but
uh they found out that the majority of
the support for kyle rittenhouse on
twitter were coming from bot accounts
from china russia hilarious oh my gosh
yeah it was it was shout out to china
dude yeah i mean the digital warfare
[ __ ] yeah the digital warfare divide
us yeah exactly create more divisiveness
in the country you know
because even his legal fees were paid by
people in support of him right like they
raised like two million dollars they
raised a [ __ ] ton of money for him which
is why his his defense was really
[ __ ] good yeah you know
that
that is a representation like just you
know embarrass themselves yeah yeah like
what were what was going to happen in
this case too they he had the money and
the backing and like once again people
are calling him a political hero
he's not a hero of any kind i don't
think there's heroes on any side there's
no hero in this it's as if like a bunch
of
dumbass batman's all got together didn't
know who was the good guy or the bad guy
and they all started this [ __ ] exactly
and they all got caught and they all got
put on trial yeah but that you know the
whole case man just shows how
politically divided the country is and
to be honest i don't think it needed to
get as polarizing at it as it became but
it just shows you man like people
this tribe mentality you know if you're
of a certain tribe it's like you gotta
hate the other side and like again latch
onto whatever you can to support your
own in this case political ideologies
and ideas and thoughts and all of that
[ __ ] and it's just like that's the
interesting thing too like i wonder how
many times i can say this and also a lot
of other people who are part of social
media and understand how this engine
runs i don't know how many [ __ ] times
i can tell people that social media
isn't real like you have to understand
not just in like people who use it but
as you just said a majority of the
people that were tweeting things in
support of kyle ridden house were
[ __ ] bots from china against against
countries that we don't exactly have the
best relationships with
this
some type of hearsay yeah this is proven
this is fact and people don't find that
alarming yeah they don't think like oh
this is an issue they're like oh but
he's still a piece of [ __ ] now let's go
back to this for a second right it's
like
do you understand why there are so
there's so much progress with other
countries like specifically talked about
like china's progress right like right
now compared to ours is because they're
doing a great job of [ __ ] conquering
and dividing us right now it's
and we always talk about this this this
idea of um what it is to be an american
they go oh we have a sense of unity here
no we [ __ ] don't my definition of
american is vastly different from a lot
of other people in this country we don't
have this sole identity of what it is to
be an american citizen we don't i would
argue we're more divided than ever
actually yeah yeah um and then a lot of
is thanks to trump because the
republican party right now well i'm not
going to say in its entirety but some
some core republican people
just literally are like the [ __ ]
joker they just want to watch the world
burn just don't care as long as they win
as long as they win as long as they
maintain power as long as they're able
to get what they want they're willing to
say and do anything which is absolutely
[ __ ] disgusting it's it's kind of
it's it's really sad to like i honestly
feel like in my personal opinion that if
you're in like high political power you
should not be able to have a social
media account
i think it's just too dangerous
you know
it's so [ __ ] dangerous too because
like because like you know with the
obviously because of how
you know former president trump
portrayed himself at the things that he
said and the things that he did
now we're left with an invalid as a
president
like this guy is barely awake
but would you rather accept someone who
is able-bodied to tweet for him or the
crazy man himself to to i just don't
think he should be able to tweet at all
yeah
yeah absolutely nothing again pick your
poison situation and then we'll see who
really gives a [ __ ] about uh politics
and the state of this country in terms
of what these people are about because
now you have to do the effort and do
your own research aside from the stuff
that twitter says right asides from
their these little blurbs and beliefs
but it's not ever going to change the
fact that misinformation is going to
spread like wildfire you know and it's
also the way it's portrayed i mean look
at the
24-hour news
you know tv shows like how they're
programmed and how they're presented
yeah they're [ __ ] sportscenter yeah
yeah
highlights i know you know it's it's
like
breaking [ __ ] noise everything's
breaking yeah the amount of breaking
news we have in the
united states is like holy [ __ ]
foreign that's why it's like i i was
hoping when biden got elected that you
know things would be a lot more boring
again it's not you know if politics was
boring you'd get a lot more [ __ ] done i
swear to god but then
you know what a lot more people get
involved because it's
news has become a sportscast yeah you
know they take all their cues from
sportscenter and there's because of that
there's i mean so much hate against each
side you know if you're on one side you
just hate everything about that other
side there's no common ground it seems
like you know what i mean you know and i
think everybody's kind of coming to the
uh
obviously we're sidetracking a little
bit but just to kind of top this off is
everybody's coming to the realization
that with this last election nobody
wants
everybody
we all lost and nobody got the president
they wanted nobody yeah you know i mean
anyone really want a [ __ ] demented
like 90 year old man to be president
we talked about a 90 year old man to be
the ceo of your company yeah you know
like we also talked about this too on
the podcast multiple times that saying
that the reason why i'm voting for this
presence because it's better than this
guy it's kind of dangerous and we talked
about that too and a lot of people
didn't agree they didn't think so
they're like it's going to get better
but how how was having somebody who had
two [ __ ] brain surgeries doesn't know
where he's at like honestly if he if he
drank a bottle of water on tv you would
see it dribble out the other side
well i think his current approval
ratings reflect
people sentiment about you know
about how they feel yeah so anyway let's
move on to the next question let's get
into meats of it man what was captured
on video each shooting was captured on
video the civil unrest in kenosha was
heavily documented the night of the
shootings and the digital media
including footage has helped
investigators in written house defense
team established a timeline of events in
the jury so videos of the shootings from
bystanders and videographers played a
major role in the blah blah blah right
so other videos show written house
fleeing after shooting rosenbaum and a
crowd of people pursuing him some
yelling beat him up
hey get him he shot him get him get that
dude yeah prior to the second shooting
rittenhouse says he tripped and fell to
the ground yep video shows him down on
the street at which point huber tried to
take his gun before written how shot and
killed him
cell phone video shows written house
walking away from the scene and tor and
towards police vehicles with his hands
raised shortly after rittenhouse shot a
third victim
uh gaichi
uh gage gage grosskroots in the arm
gross crews was holding a handgun at the
time he was shot written lawyers claim
he acted in self defense yeah so okay
let's get into the meat of this now
since you broke that part down so
basically here's the timeline right and
um i i'm pretty sure that i have the
details accurate here but if i'm wrong
you guys can fact check me on this but
basically
um yeah uh rittenhouse his his first um
kind of moment with with one of the
people who were killed was rosenbaum
right yeah now he's getting chased
right
and
rosenbaum throws his bag of clothes at
written house that he had because he was
discharged from the hospital yeah it was
like a bag of sauce right it was like a
bag of his clothing items right it's
just socks yeah
80 pairs of socks
he knows he's being chased by this guy
who's who's basically yeah who's already
threatened him previously right so he
has his back turned to it kyle has his
back turned to him this guy's chasing me
throw something at him somebody fires
off two shots i believe
now
you put yourself in written house's
shoes
you have your back turned somebody who's
hostile against you is chasing you and
you hear gunshots very closely behind
you
is it safe to assume that he thinks his
life is in danger
yeah right i would right also too i also
want to note that you know when it comes
to the stuff that we're saying um i have
yet to read something from anybody that
refutes this
so nobody has come out saying like no
actually kyle rittenhouse had a gun and
tried to shoot him well it's impossible
because there's video evidence exactly
so like
but even if people had that thing in
their head they're like oh according to
whose account right
yeah
if they don't want to believe that no
matter how much evidence and facts that
are out there they would have lost yeah
at that point so so okay that's that's
leading up to now rose and bomb lunging
at him and trying to get physical with
him right then kyle rittenhouse fires
off his shots right now moving on after
he he he shoots him um he runs out into
the streets and while he's running in
the streets like you mentioned in the
article people are yelling get him you
know
he's he has a gun whatever right yeah
now nobody knows though at that point
who they're referring to because it's
chaos in the streets it's like people
are pointing like this everyone's saying
get him he's the guy right
kyle rittenhouse is running but there's
a lot of other people running as well in
the streets and now kyle rittenhouse is
being chased and this kid trips there's
an assailant who didn't get shot who
actually kicks him in the head first
when he falls
kyle
lets off a shot
while he's on the ground it's not like
he had the gun pointed at him he gets
hit then he fires off a shot he misses
that guy the guy disappears out of the
frame right he got away unscathed then
anthony huber comes in with this
skateboard hits him
i believe kicks him and then he grabs
his rifle tries to take his gun but
while he's trying to take the gun kyle's
able to get a shot off that shot happens
to be a fatal wound to the chest right
again it wasn't an aimed shot it was in
the heat of the moment he let off that
shot boom that guy collapses to the
floor and then now
uh gross croots he's the only survivor
who gave the testimony he comes in the
frame now he puts his hands up like this
while kyle rittenhouse is on the floor
he has his gun pointed at him
and then all of a sudden he puts his
hand down and points his gun at kyle
rittenhouse that's when kyle fires a
shot off so now at none of these points
if you look at all the video evidence
that's out there was there any clear
sign of provocation by kyle rittenhouse
yeah he was trying to avoid conflict he
was trying to run away saying friendly
friendly he was trying to protect
himself he just had a gun to do it yeah
now again for the people who are
listening who might not be happy with
the verdict
put yourself in his shoes in these
moments you have a gun you got people
trying to attack you you have assailants
coming after you
you can realistically fear for your life
in that moment legit mob right and the
hard part is for people too is that
what i know everybody wants to say is he
shouldn't have been there in the first
place the other people shouldn't have
either and 100 true but the fact of the
matter is he was there so we can't talk
about the what ifs
he was there and so were they right so
to say he shouldn't have been there in
the by the way i'm guilty of this too
because when this case first came out i
was just riled up with emotions yeah and
i didn't get to take a look at this for
what actually happened and obviously
there wasn't
the the data that we have now wasn't
there right and i clearly jumped the gun
once again
i'm not saying i like this kid yeah you
don't have to i'm talking about what
happened here right and at the end of
the day when i look at it and i looked
at those multiple videos we saw all the
angles
he didn't provoke these people not at
all not at all but and once again to say
he shouldn't have been there in the
first place doesn't allow for you to
convict him as guilty right it's not
going to work like that in court it
doesn't work like how are you going to
control that at all yeah like even on
the other side rosenbaum how are you
going to let a crazy man join your
protest
how are you going to stop that yeah and
by the way getting discharged too once
again
if you were in
just not his place let's just let's take
that part out right because the the
i wouldn't be like him fine you are
going to be judged in court for whatever
thing right and the only defense for the
the prosecution comes with well you
shouldn't have been there in the first
place and they go guilty you're right
take him out of there would
you be like what the [ __ ] yeah right the
whole idea of the trial is because he
was there right that's right exactly and
look let's let's close out the series of
events that that transpired is after he
shoots gross croots he shoots him in the
arm right he doesn't kill him
he gets up he starts running towards the
police with his hands up uh the the gun
at his waist basically saying i was
involved in a shooting you know i i shot
somebody does that look like the body
language and behavior of somebody who
was out for a killing spree that that
was out to [ __ ] kill these people
like willingly surrendering because the
cops have no idea what happened at that
point he willingly went up to them
telling them but the cops didn't arrest
him until the next day yeah right
so apparently he walked up to them and
one cop pepper sprayed oh yeah and then
he got pepper sprayed and they told him
to go home so he was like what the [ __ ]
okay he tried to turn himself in yeah
yeah he did he did try to turn it like
get out of here yeah perspective i
didn't know about the pepper spray so he
went home that's why he went home yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] hard
i'm trying to do the right thing
oh
[ __ ]
you're breaking curfew
which by the way was supposed to be one
of the charges which they dropped yeah
yeah because i mean you know everybody
was breaking yeah but look man basically
you can't go into a chaotic situation
and not expect chaotic things to happen
that's just foolish
when i participated in the blm movements
i went out there with pure intentions to
be part of a peaceful protest you know
get this agenda up on the map and
whatever show my support but in the back
of my head i knew at any point some [ __ ]
can pop off yes cops can come i could
get pepper sprayed i could get into an
altercation with some of these writers
or looters if they showed up because i
did have that intention i was like if i
see a writer or looter i'm gonna i'm
gonna intervene you know so i didn't go
into it thinking oh it's gonna be all
you know peachy and rosy i i like i'm
like yeah i i'm here for a peaceful
protest but i'm also fully you went to a
nice part of it when i went to that
protest i came in i had to park hella
far because obviously it was kind of
crazy yeah when i came in i saw a car
burn i left i'm like this
what the [ __ ] yeah
when there was that big one on hollywood
boulevard yeah like apparently they were
supposed to be in cape town too like
meeting up at hollywood and when i heard
that i actually had a panic attack
because
you know the 92 rights my family lost
[ __ ] everything right right i drove
my ass to k-town so [ __ ] fast and
like i was
crying like i i had this crazy panic
attack like i don't want to see that
[ __ ] happen again yeah yeah and same
deal like yeah i was going there because
i'm going to go to my house house and i
need to protect her yeah so if anything
[ __ ] happens yeah i'm on my toes
exactly i don't have a gun yeah i know
that's all i can do is like i'm going to
be prepared thank god when i got there
the national guard was already
protecting downtown yeah but like i get
it like if you're walking into that
situation knowingly you're right you if
you're you have to be on your toes right
something could absolutely and i do want
people to be clear if you are somebody
who is at home sitting on the couch
talking about how you would feel if you
were in that situation you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about dude
like i went to a total of three protests
two of them were nice one of them wasn't
right the feel even at the nice protest
i felt really uneasy when you see a car
burning in front of you and you see
people screaming at the top of their
lungs throwing [ __ ] yeah your your
spidey senses are up you don't feel safe
at all you start sweating it's it's a
different [ __ ] feeling yeah and to to
talk about what you would have done when
you have never been in those type of
situations it's very presumptuous of you
right and
it's scary it's actually
[ __ ] frightening right so now imagine
that environment and people actually
coming to attack you yes when you're
trying to avoid conflict now if i if
california had an open carry law you
best damn believe i would have had my
gun yeah you know what i mean yeah and
i'm not i'm not bringing that gun
necessarily with the intention to use it
on somebody but something should i pop
up if some [ __ ] does pop off and i have
to use it to protect myself reasonably
protect myself then i will yeah
not because i want to kill somebody not
because i want to hurt somebody but it's
like if you're trying to hurt me or if
you're trying to even kill me
and it's me or you i find it hilarious
that they pepper sprayed and told
let's move on to the next part so we're
going to talk about the or i'm going to
read about uh
what the prosecutors were trying to do
uh the prosecution attempted to he's
[ __ ] close clowns
the prosecution attempted to discredit
the core of his defense by questioning
why a teenager who possessed an ar-15
style rifle would feel that his life was
in danger
thomas binger
the lead prosecutor tried to depict
written house as an armed threat signing
witness accounts who claim the teen
raised his gun in the direction of
others throughout the night you're
telling us that you felt you were about
to die right but when you point the gun
at someone else that's going to make
them feel that they're about to die
right
that's what you wanted him to feel
binger said flustered and on the verge
of tears rittenhouse claimed one of the
victims could have run away instead of
trying to take his gun prosecutors
introduced a drone video showing written
how shooting joseph rosenbaum at close
range after rosabom had followed the
teen the footage depicted the clearest
images yet of the event that set in
motion the bloodshed that followed
prosecutors brought forward several
witnesses including dominic black a
friend of written houses who faced his
own trial for buying the 17 year old an
ar-15 style rifle he wasn't old enough
to legally possess he testified that
rittenhouse called him seconds after the
first shooting saying i shot somebody i
shot somebody he described rittenhouse
as freaking out and really scared
however some of the government
government's witnesses may have been
more helpful to the defense strategy
that anticipated
martin howard a kenosha police detective
testified that rittenhouse shouted
friendly friendly friendly as he was
being chased by rosenbaum and agreed
with the defense's character
characterization that their
confrontation appeared to look like the
classic ambush
prosecutors made extensive use of the
footage from the shootings during their
closing arguments let me tell you
something about the prosecution
already off the bat yeah you see this it
seems that everything they brought
forward didn't work for them no
they said about rosenbaum that they
would have probably prosecuted him if he
was alive that was the prosecution so
it's like you're not doing yourself any
favors here bro what are you trying to
do did you forget whose side you're on
right now like so this is the thing too
that i was so
just irritated about is
from what krusty the clown [ __ ] legal
team did they get this guy from oh
that's the district
yeah just sideshow bob here yeah
you know
it's you know that's that's state
yeah yeah that's the state yeah that
[ __ ] like even when you read this
article they talked about oh they they
brought one of the cops in and it turned
out to work
for the defense yeah you know actually
he was saying friendly friendly friendly
they're like okay well hold on a second
wait what yeah
that's not what you were supposed to say
yeah and even the gage dude even they
had a big he had a big moment on the
stand too right yeah when he admitted
she [ __ ] pointed a gun so he was
trying to initially not bring that
detail into the picture but when he was
asked point blank
you know he's like yes
i did point the gun at him so you know
look the prosecution team were [ __ ]
clowns for sure like trying to link call
of duty like questioning kyle
rittenhouse you play call of duty right
they were trying to use that to
basically paint this guy as a vigilante
looking for blood they're painting him
like as if he was a school shooter yeah
exactly no no that's exactly how they
were trying to paint it but look the
media were [ __ ] guilty of that [ __ ]
too yeah they were trying to paint this
kid now again it doesn't matter whether
or not you like him
based on what you know about him you
know what i mean it it's give
him
his fair trial with the details and the
facts
this guy this kid might be an intel but
he wouldn't shoot up a school now
exactly but if call of duty is the
prerequisite to be a mass killer oh boy
man all of us are guaranteed trouble
so i mean so the prosecution at this
point um
what they're always going to try to do
is put in question
his character as a human being right and
one of the most hilarious things that i
read was they brought in question i
believe it was either his instagram or
or twitch handle he was like your twitch
handle is uh four doors more [ __ ]
right
[Applause]
they were also trying to paint him as
kind of like a white supremacist like
saying that he was holding up white
supremacist signs and photos that was at
the at the bar right right at the bar so
i'm not sure what happened first like so
he got a big fundraiser and got bailed
out right yes and then immediately went
to a bar with the proud boys you guys
know the proud boys are yeah yeah yeah
right
now yeah yeah well i mean they're a
bunch of [ __ ] insult
loser ass white dudes who racists who
are led by a minority yeah a white
supremacist led by a [ __ ] puerto
rican i believe yes they feel like
they're losing this country and that
white men need to step up or some [ __ ]
like that i mean it's all under like
undertoned yeah but generally it's a
white power thing so that's when he did
the okay sign yeah but apparently that's
supposed to be the new white right
this also means you get punched too you
know like kids do this [ __ ] all the time
i didn't know that yeah because i do
okays all the time yeah so i don't know
like if especially when i'm driving
somebody wants to go through i go yeah
apparently the three here is white is w
for white yeah
if all right written house after the
verdict and everything now he the
interview was with fox new fox news with
tucker crescent god i [ __ ] hate
tucker carlson but yeah rittenhouse came
and said look man i'm not a racist i
support the blm movement
would a white supremacist
go on record of saying on fox news yeah
yeah i support
that's kind of rough
from all everything that i've read and
so far it didn't seem like he was there
being a counter protester he was there
trying to put out fires and like doing
his
record to actually helping people yeah
like he just had a [ __ ] assault rifle
on him a [ __ ] dweeb that's what i've
said a [ __ ] dumb ass batman out there
yeah well he got bullied when he was
younger and he actually dropped out of
high school and all that so maybe he's a
little socially awkward too who knows
but oh [ __ ] so he could have been a
school shooter
i
this is the hard pill for a lot of
people to swallow right yeah i'm saying
i'll keep saying this throughout the
podcast [ __ ] me too
like
but i can't deny the things that i'm
reading and also seeing yeah it's just
as a human being i can't do that because
once again if we do want the justice
system to be fair just because it didn't
work out the way that you wanted to
doesn't mean that it wasn't fair right
given the law and the evidence and the
circumstances yeah yes
so let's go into what the attorney says
the shootings were in self-defense this
is his attorneys right so this is the
defense yeah the defense argues written
house acted in self-defense they had a
witness who spoke to the timeline of
events in attempt to give credibility to
written houses claims he felt threatened
and another who was present that night
and referred to those protesting police
brutality as violent rioters and antifa
the defense called several witnesses
over two and a half days including
rittenhouse who was given the
opportunity to tell his side of the
story uh written house described the
moments leading up to his interaction
with joseph rosenbaum the first man he
shot and killed and depicted rosenbaum
as the aggressor who ambushed him the
defense claimed rosenbaum made verbal
threats against written house's life and
accusation the state disputes saying he
had no means to carry out his threat
so he still threatened him
um yeah i think that much is pretty
clear yeah yeah that he was threatened
in all the situations yeah all the
altercations britain now said he did not
notice rosenbaum until he ran out from
behind the car at that point joshua
zaminski
who has since been charged with
disorderly conduct step forward
toward stepped toward him with a pistol
in his hand causing rittenhouse to drop
the fire extinguisher he was holding and
making him take a step back over his
shoulder written house said he saw
rosenbaum running from the side right
side saying he was cornered
rittenhouse recalled how he felt he
needed to run away from rosebomb after
seeing him gaining speed it written
house's direction with his arms out i
didn't want to have to kill mr rosenbaum
britain how said when asked why he
continued firing after the first shot he
said i continued to shoot until he was
no longer a threat to me
rittenhouse claimed he wanted to turn
himself into the police but ahmad began
chasing him as he was running
rittenhouse encountered huber who he
says struck him in the back of the head
with his skateboard which we saw in the
video
after uh falling to the ground
rittenhouse said a group of people
surrounded him and he pointed his gun
toward them hubert did not back off and
rittenhouse claims hubert kicked him in
the face and then struck him in the neck
with his skateboard renthouse claimed
hubert reached for his weapon when he
fired uh one shot into his chest shortly
after that the teen said he then lowered
his weapon and spotted gross crews he
said he noticed that gross crews had a
pistol in his hand and shot him once in
the arm yeah so i mean basically we
discussed all these points you know but
yeah it's not like written house was
[ __ ] going on a rampage just emptying
clips on people you know yeah
the media did a really good job of
influencing me too and i felt that he
was this guy looking for [ __ ] trouble
yeah um
you thought he was a crazy kid right
like everything yeah yeah like a
bloodthirsty crazy kid who had a gun and
he was out there looking for to take
lives you know yeah but dude
it actually surprises me for a kid that
young
how measured he was in his ability to
only fire off one shot or two because he
he was in panic mode right yeah so he
could have easily let off you know like
multiple shots just out of panic but how
measured he was in
just only getting off what he saw was
necessary or what he thought was
necessary in the given moment yeah is
surprising to me so
um is that
covering the part where he act he has
that panic attack and starts crying oh
that's when he's on on the stand oh that
wasn't how i understand so yeah that's
another thing right it's dude like the
comment sections on the video on youtube
they're just [ __ ] clowning this guy
i'm like dude i kind of actually feel
bad for the kid man because like is that
the reaction of a [ __ ] bloodthirsty
killer nah that's ptsd
yeah panic attack from ptsd as this guy
is recounting what happened you know
what i mean like
i actually feel bad yeah i didn't
like a lot of celebrities uh tweets
about it lebron's specifically lebron i
didn't see a single team lebron
lebron got roasted super hard yeah
they're like hey he's like listen this
guy is the biggest fake crier in all the
nba so he could he could cite fake
crying like nobody else yeah but you
know like when i look at that and i look
at it over a couple of times i'll be
real i giggled a little bit
and then
you know i giggled a little bit
and the second part the second part i
was like i'm an 18 year old about to be
put in jail for life i would freak the
[ __ ] out yeah and it did look like a
crazy panic attack yeah um yeah i only
said it because i've had my own panic
attacks yeah and i don't cry but i
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah
dude you could tell this too was [ __ ]
freaking out bro like i wouldn't even be
able to stand stand there i'd be like
[ __ ] yeah he couldn't even get a word
out anymore you know but but look
with this with this whole incident um
and people
thinking like anthony hebert thinking
that he was an active shooter because
people were yelling you know get him
whatever he has a gun
critical thinking skills here guys
both can be true
anthony huber could have realistically
thought that he was an active shooter
and tried to stop him and kyle
rittenhouse could have realistically
thought or reasonably thought i would
say that he was an assailant trying to
harm him or even kill him and try things
can be true at once and i just talked
about this
at once exactly this this is why i like
look at our humanity like we are a bunch
of [ __ ] monkeys when it comes down to
it you know like can you imagine like
this like as as if we're all caveman
chimps you know like
when when the [ __ ] goes down you go to
your primal instincts and it's just this
war of different monkey clans coming at
you absolutely self preservation gun gun
everyone's like
[ __ ] they oh get the guy with the gun
right like yeah that's but they didn't
know who he was right in our dna bro
self-preservation is what dates back to
our beginning right that's that's that's
how we're programmed and so if somebody
or something is threatening that then
our reaction is is going to be all right
also too i got to live you know based on
the the characterization of a couple of
the people who
were killed
um
who's also to say that those people
didn't say active shooter because they
wanted him to get [ __ ] killed too to
get [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah they wanted
him to get hurt they wanted him to get
yeah maybe not kill but to get hurt yeah
at the very least get him let's say he
didn't have a gun and he was there doing
his emt thing
a crazy guy like rosenbaum could have
went after him anyway yeah because he
was already upset at him for putting on
a fire right yeah yeah what would have
happened then if he didn't have a gun
then he would have got this [ __ ] kicked
out of him rosenbaum was already
creating tension with people out there
yeah he was yelling at people and you
know so again nobody knows what his
purpose for being out there was
um but you want to talk about anybody
looking for trouble
that guy seemed like he was looking for
trouble you know so closing arguments so
closing arguments took place monday with
lawyers on the two sides each getting
two and a half hours to present their
arguments judge bruce schroeder
then informed the jury that they are
charged with weighing the evidence and
implored them to return just and true
verdicts after breaking for the night
the jury returned to begin deliberations
tuesday morning the panel of 18 jurors
who heard the case was winnowed down to
12 who will decide the verdict seven
women and five men after their numbers
were placed on pieces of paper and a
lottery uh tumbler in the courtroom and
rittenhouse himself picked six pieces of
paper that were used to identify the
alternate uh jurors
and that's all that was written at the
time for this
so you know hearing all this stuff it's
it's kind of hard to process right it's
just so much [ __ ] that happened but
there was just weird i mean
we read a lot of like these media
articles too right i think
clearly a lot of the stuff that i'm
reading that's presented to me because i
think the scenes that that i tend to
look at specifically in comedy tends to
be a lot more liberal so things are
going to be fed to me that way yeah
basically a liberal lens
so a lot of the stuff that was pointed
out was uh trying to discredit the judge
um oh yeah that that definitely was
happening i mean there was definitely a
few women he was a [ __ ] weirdo he was
a [ __ ] weirdo because like his cell
phone went off and it was i'm proud to
be an american
also too
him making everybody stand and give a
round of applause veterans day for
veterans day to one of the people that
was going to be a part of the defense
for kyle rittenhouse what the [ __ ] are
you thinking what do you think people
are going to take from that you jackass
yeah you know so he was a really [ __ ]
weirdo
[Music]
he was a weird guy but i i don't think
that it prevented him from doing his job
you know yeah it's not about what it
prevented him from doing his job is
we've already learned time and time
again that public perception is very
important in keeping calm with with the
public yeah like what the [ __ ] are you
thinking you're a judge conduct yourself
properly you have to do a great job yeah
keep that [ __ ] out of the courtroom yeah
isn't that your job today he's like put
yourself in contempt he made everybody
[ __ ] give this guy a round of
applause
yeah you give him a round of applause
what's that gonna look like to the
[ __ ] public you did no justice for
anybody in that sense in terms of what
it looks like to the public because
people are looking for anything and he's
still deciding to do this stupid [ __ ]
like even making like the the [ __ ]
the the corona joke like the chinese
food joke or whatever it's like why do
this here dude
yeah people are looking to discredit you
any type of way why would you do this it
was poor judgment
pun intended
this guy is so weird yeah imagine
someone else's phone went off in there
yeah like [ __ ] donald trump yeah
yeah nobody's supposed to have their
phone on in there right yeah so why did
his phone go off yeah it just it just
was so i'm saying this this whole [ __ ]
was so weird it's like what the [ __ ] was
he thinking
and like um there was another thing with
msnbc like they got kicked out of the
courtroom yeah because they [ __ ]
followed the jury to their hotel yeah
but that that's they're bad you know
like that's clearly their bad yeah i
also read how um a couple of the jurors
were seen to be crying or visibly upset
and they were just super [ __ ] pissed
that this is how they had to judge it
yeah
verdict apparently they were just really
mad at the process right i'm sure
they're for them too you know that the
emotions are running high but they're
trying for the for the sake of the case
put those emotions aside and make an
objective decision which they did yeah
they did shows they did yeah they did
beyond their emotions even though it did
upset yeah look again man it's important
to point out just because you
can accept like
the the verdict that that was handed
down doesn't mean you have to like it
you know doesn't mean that you have to
like it you can even feel very strongly
about it but it was based on the laws of
wisconsin i mean um
um [ __ ] blinking here kenosha kenosha
yeah yeah kenosha wisconsin yeah yeah um
it was wisconsin i don't know if i i'm
like yeah having a brain fart but yeah
it was based on their laws their gun
laws and so
what bothers me i guess is me saying
that it was the right call and i'm
looking at it objectively groups me in
with these [ __ ] fringe far right
groups you know these cuckoo heads right
yeah
i'm not that though i'm just a
reasonable person who has critical
thinking skills and can look at the
evidence and be like you know what
the right call was made here yeah and i
i think only you know
like serious boneheads would see this as
a win
you know kind of thing i don't think
anybody [ __ ] wins this is bad for
everybody people died bro
people on the right are using it to for
their political agenda and like those
people too it's just for them to come
out and say you know what he is a true
political hero he's an american hero
what in the [ __ ] what's that you're
doing in what sense yeah how is he a
hero he makes him a [ __ ] hero kids
are [ __ ] morons there are no heroes
in this this is exactly what watchmen is
about you know watchmen is about a bunch
of crazy
like morons who put on costumes who want
to be superheroes and bad [ __ ] happens
to them you know essentially right right
you know right on the overlying theme of
the whole story yeah you know it's like
how far off are we as a society like
that this kid
you know like
where he's gonna go be an emt or
whatever yeah there yeah
but i'm going to take my ar-15 with me
that's some weird [ __ ] puncture
it's very stupid and again poor judgment
and he's young so obviously he's you
know going to make stupid decisions but
what my take away from this case is one
yeah the gun laws in america especially
within certain states are very
problematic they're gonna have to redo
that [ __ ] well that's you know that's
something that's been talked about for
years in this country right with all the
[ __ ] mass shootings here and killings
with that that's one takeaway from it
and two is
my concern is that even though i think
this was the right call the precedent
might set for people who do want to you
know do
like be a vigilante and and be out there
and do these things because i don't
think that was written house's intention
yeah absolutely you know oh that's the
[ __ ] show it's turned into right yeah is
that now people who are the counter
protesters are like [ __ ] yeah i can take
my gun to the next beat
kill these people you know and i could i
could be you know
let go of these charges that's how they
[ __ ] see it now yeah that's my
concern you know but again it's like
those are the laws yeah and i think
you know just to wrap up that we talked
about in the podcast is
you know beyond just that people are
also very upset because they can't help
specifically the black community can't
help but feel
in these cases like if that if kyle
rittenhouse was a black kid absolutely
would he have gotten away absolutely
this is what he would have gotten the
same not guilty verdict would have been
pepper sprayed
yeah
but this is how i feel and this is what
the president's in the reason why i feel
there's precedence to this because of
what this country has showed yeah and
that's the other thing to as to why
people can't
feel that justice was served and it's
because they almost want injustice to
happen because of the injustice that
happened in them and that's what feels
fair yeah because if it was on the other
shoe would have happened this way and a
lot of people confidently can say that
no i truly don't believe that that's
what would have happened so in order for
them to feel justified they want
injustice to happen to kyle written
house too because to them that is what's
fair it's hard for me to tell them
not to feel that way because honestly i
feel that way too
but you can't right a wrong with another
wrong i just don't believe in that no so
yeah the what the case should be is that
yeah that type of equal justice should
apply to all you know so whether kyle
rittenhouse is a white man a black man
an asian man mexican man doesn't matter
the the verdict would be the same
regardless but
yeah what some of these people are angry
about rightfully so is
the fact that you can't definitively say
oh yeah no it would have been the same
but the fact that there's even a
question mark yeah the fact that it's
questionable at best
makes it a problem yeah and and that's a
glaring issue in this country clearly
right and this case just kind of brought
more attention to that fact and
it's just like well
still it doesn't take away from what
this kid did yeah and how he handled
himself i mean the way
i mean he's a free man now i mean i
think i just saw a picture where he went
to florida and he met with trump at
mar-a-lago
you know the dude the right is [ __ ]
loving it they love it so much
and he got offered an internship by uh
the some florida congressman
um
like yo you want to give this guy a job
offer now after all this [ __ ] right
right so you could come into politics
and now be a face for what
exactly to
you know like that's commendable yeah
like i i can't understand like who wants
o.j to be on their party
exactly exactly what's up twitter
what's up democrats
but i think too that you know kyle
getting this type of um
love and like the
embracement that he's getting from that
community it must feel good too
considering that he was bullied and he
even dropped out of high school because
of it now all of a sudden he has this
community who's like putting him on a
pedestal and being like they're yeah
they love me
i hope this kid has people around him
that also can tell that humble him and
tell him like listen you shouldn't have
been there in the [ __ ] first place
yeah and well i think he even realizes
that because you know the lawyer his
lawyer had said that um if he could take
it back he wouldn't have gone out yeah
yeah he wouldn't have gone there because
of what's happened you know so there's
like the lawyer didn't want to use the
word regret right or anything that might
paint him to be looking guilty but it
was an indirect way it was pretty clear
what he was saying was that kyle regrets
being there yeah he wishes he wasn't
there
it's just it's it's weird man and i know
some people are going to listen to this
podcast and i'm kind of uh interested to
what people say and there's probably
some details that we're missing um i
mean i've read this
pretty pretty pretty thoroughly i think
the details we covered is pretty much
like the main chunks of it you're a
racist bro don't even talk yes
and you love kyle rittenhouse yeah
that's the thing it's such a hot take
right now for me to say that was the
right call it's like oh you wrote white
supremacy yeah what the [ __ ] are you
talking i'm like
did you and it's appalling to me because
some of the people that i've had this
conversation with
once you get into it they actually don't
know any of the details of the case well
that's what i'm saying yeah and i was
like i was that person
i'm gonna write the details and i'm like
oh you said i'm wrong i'm like oh so
what are you basing it off of then
headlines
sensationalism um so what did they say
though i'm so curious it's just like you
know the whole thing about the judge
being biased right yeah things like that
that that the media was trying to
portray to kind of discredit this whole
uh case yeah before i read up into it i
literally thought he went there with a
gun to start some [ __ ] yeah i'm not
gonna lie that's just that's what i had
thought to do from like kind of the
cursory details i was getting about it
i'm like oh this [ __ ] is guilty
for that i'm sure yeah you know like
this guy was out there he was a [ __ ]
crit well it doesn't help that he was
white with the uh because every massive
and he was wearing those gloves but he
was wearing those gloves because he was
trying to do some medical [ __ ]
obviously the optics look bad and it's
just like this pyeongchang didn't even
think ahead of what he was doing yeah he
just wanted to serve a life's purpose
maybe because of being dropped out of
high school perhaps he's like because he
went through emt training yeah he's
going to find a purpose in his life you
want to utilize it out there in the real
world in a real situation yeah
but like what [ __ ] ambulance have you
seen with a bunch of [ __ ] emts
pulling out their guns and [ __ ] you know
it's just it sucks you know the whole
situation [ __ ] sucks yeah and i i
feel like i mean hope i wonder what
people are going to say like if you
really did read up on everything and
then you saw the video too it's not just
reading up it's it's seeing with our own
eyes watching the trial the whole trial
is [ __ ] available for you to watch
you can watch every single second of it
if you want and it sucks too because i'm
sitting there thinking and i feel
i feel bad i feel like a bad person
because
i a part of me wants him to go to jail
but then i know he doesn't deserve to be
there yeah and that makes me feel like a
bad person and it kind of makes me a bad
person if i think about it but if i if i
was a part of that journey and i really
wanted to look it at the extent of the
law i probably would have said he wasn't
guilty yeah and that's the hard pill for
me to swallow yeah me reading a thread
say the same thing yeah yeah and look
man again the whole uh miner uh with the
firearm that charge it was just a
misdemeanor so he probably would have
served like a handful of months or
something it was it wouldn't have been i
think it's nine months it was like the
maximum right so he probably would he
have served yeah he probably wouldn't
have served he could even just gotten
house arrest or community service or
something right yeah but now he he's
free to have more guns now right right
right he's 18 now yeah but yeah so like
that charge but again because of their
statute in wisconsin law
i mean based on that it's like well
i mean that's pretty [ __ ] stupid this
is moronic but
it's the law now does the state have to
pay his legal expenses that i don't know
because apparently there's a new debate
now if kyle ridden house to just keep
that two million dollars that was raised
from oh so now he's this [ __ ] is
a millionaire too
oh i'd be able to believe that [ __ ] yeah
i would be so mad my crypto has been
tanking
i would be so [ __ ] bad right now dude
dude it's like god damn like now you
think about like kids who thinking about
doing school shootings no let's go shoot
up a protest yeah yeah and i think
there's like let me be a meal yeah
i think there's a lot of important
lessons to take away from this but again
man like
for me like i just said when i had first
caught like the cursory details i
thought you know i had a preconceived
notion white kid he has a [ __ ] you
know rifle oh for sure this was out for
like blood he was looking for blood yeah
but but that was private thoughts i
didn't go oh let me go on twitter this
motherfucker's guilty i'm like let me
tell me i put that in the podcast
i was pretty sure about it let me let me
do my due diligence here and let me look
into actually what happened and the more
i looked into it and the more i learned
i was like holy [ __ ] i i was wrong you
know i was wrong about this this this
kid clearly was defending himself and he
just happened to have a gun to be able
to do that his jackass of a kid was
defending himself
hey man the justice system saves and
protects dumb people too yeah yeah it
does it does absolutely and you also
want this justice system to work for you
in this favor and once again i'm
hopefully if it wasn't a white boy it
would have happened the same way yeah
yeah that would be what we hope that
would be the hope but again the fact
that it's questionable that's the
problem you know within the country
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast i'm curious to
see what you guys think about the case
and if you did read every article you
saw the court proceedings you saw the
video i'm so curious if you guys were a
part of the jury what you guys would
have uh convicted him for
uh specifically for the charges that
were brought up against him i'm curious
guilty
you know what my heart says but you know
what my brain says yeah there's gonna be
some fx drama you know about it you know
the people versus renouncing for sure
yeah yeah i would like to have a
conversation with this kid just like
what the [ __ ] were you thinking
yeah so you want to save people and put
carry
dude just be a medic for the marines man
yeah dude just pepper spray works fine
too guys
but uh you can catch the genius brain
every thursday sunday's up until january
1st of next year uh next year we're only
going uh once a week
um so until then guys we'll see you all
next time you can find ed at ed parkvp
and you can find the other ed at ed2 uh
secret society as you can see the gear
that we're wearing right now here right
now uh it's out right now the back to
basics collection back to bases
collection is [ __ ] fire a lot of
oversized tees right now comfortable ass
sweaters super nice and warm looks dope
as [ __ ] by the way he actually changed
out of his sweats because he was sweaty
and i'm wearing my h m collection
shout out to h
i got a [ __ ] big booty it keeps me
warm
well uh yeah write in the comment
section below and let me know interact
and we'll see you all next time peace